über dieses bemerkenswerte Video spreche
ich jetzt mit dem Politikwissenschaftler
und Publizisten Albrecht von Lucke guten
Tag guten Tag Herr von Lucke
bemerkenswert das Video auch deshalb
weil Robert habbeck von bedingungsloser
staatsrison spricht und das haben in
dieser Deutlichkeit
Spitzenpolitikerinnen und Politiker in
Deutschland bisher nicht
gemacht na ja das bemerkenswerte ist vor
allem wie er staatsresung ausdefiniert
durchdekliniert und sie haben wie ich
finde mit gutem Recht diese absolut
bemerken Werte Rede in absoluter Länge
gebracht die Qualität dieser Rede und er
hat es gleich eingangs gesagt das ist
übrigens auch ein Stück weit die
implizite Begründung er sagt wir sind
jetzt fast vier Wochen nach dem
schrecklichen 7 Oktober und wir erleben
eine massive Gewalt eine Zunahme auch
des Antisemitismus auf deutschen Straßen
es ist eine Rede die die staatssison
nach innen ausdekliniert und sagt was
ist der erste Akt was ist die erste
Notwendigkeit und das macht diese Rede
zu einer die unbedingt Notwendigkeit die
das Momentum auf ihrer Seite hat die
erste Notwendigkeit einer staatssaison
ist Jüdin und Juden in Deutschland zu
schützen das macht habbeck in einer
eindringlich klarkeit klar vor allem man
merkt es am Anfang mit einem ungehören
Maß gleichermaßen auf an aufklärerischem
Willen aber auch grundiert mit Empathie
und hoher Emotionalität das wird
besonders deutlich wenn er sagt das ist
alles hier auf deutschen Straßen 80
Jahre fast 80 Jahre nach dem Holocaust
das betont er dreimal das bringt die
Dringlichkeit zum Ausdruck und das ist
das eigentlich phänomenale es ist die
erste
die anders als viele anderen die ja die
staatssison fast floskelhaft vor sich
hergetragen hab die deutlich macht was
unter staatssison zu allererst zu
verstehen ist nämlich der Schutz
jüdischen Lebens in Deutschland aber
daneben auch der Schutz die Verteidigung
Israels als die Heimstadt der Juden die
gerade momentan die Sorge hat dass sie
nicht mehr die Sicherheit bietet die sie
eigentlich 75 Jahre für Jüdin und Juden
garantieren konnte und genau das ist
gegenwärtig in Auflösung und warum hält
so eine Rede jetzt der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister auch wenn er
natürlich gleichzeitig auch Vizekanzler
ist warum hält so eine Rede nicht der
Bundeskanzler warum hält so eine Rede
nicht der
Bundespräsident dafür gibt es Gründe zum
einen natürlich die Tatsache dass wir es
mit einem speziellen
Bundeswirtschaftsminister zu tun haben
Robert Habeck ist das haben wir heute
gesehen genau der Redner den der
Bundeskanzler nicht abzugeben in der
Lage ist und frankwalter Steinmeier hält
meistens gerade jetzt ist er ja wieder
unterwegs zurückwärts gewandte reden
reden die sehr oft eher erinnern die die
historische Dimension ins Rennen bringen
er ist aber auch nicht der Mensch der
diese Qualität einer Rede hat und das
aufrüttelnde bei Steinmeier hat man ja
manchmal eher den rituellen Charakter
ODF Scholz steht dieses äh diese Rede
rhetorische Qualität gar nicht zugebote
das ist meines aachtens auch der Grund
warum Robert Habig jetzt in dieses
Vakuum springt ich sehe darin eine
absolute Dringlichkeit man merkt es
dieser rede ja an er hat über Wochen
gewartet hat vielleicht auch erhofft
dass eine solche Rede gehalten wird weil
er die Dringlichkeit sieht weil er sieht
dass wir auf deutschem Boden etwas
erleben was wir uns 75 Jahre nicht haben
vorstellen können dass Übergriffe in
einem Maße auf Jüden Juden stattfinden
dass Jüden Juden markiert werden dass
der äh der dass das Israel omblem an an
Häuser von Juden markiert wird dass also
Dinge passieren die ihn an die
schwärzesten Stunden Deutschlands
erinnern deswegen ist das eine Rede die
er als Wirtschaftsminister hält und ich
nehme an weil er es aus ein dringlichen
Notwendigkeit begreift und wir sehen ja
übrigens auch die Tatsache dass diese
Rede sofort in viele Sprachen übersetzt
worden ist zeigt dass auch das Ausland
auf eine solche Rede gewartet hat die
gewisser Maßen übersetzt was staatssison
zu allererst bedeutet der Schutz der
Jüdin und Juden auf deutschem Boden war
das aus ihrer Sicht und nach ihrer
Einschätzung abgesprochen z.B mit dem
Bundeskanzler oder war das
impulshandlung von Robert habbeck na ja
Impuls greift natürlich viel zu kurz
diese Rede ist so exzellent
ausformuliert sie ist von einer solchen
rhetorischen Wucht also man wird sich
schon sehr schnell die Frage stellen ob
das nicht genau die Rede des Jahres sein
wird wir haben ja am Ende dieses Jahres
immer eine solche präierung weil sie als
Rede auch argumentativ so klar
durchdekliniert wer ohne übrigens den
Gegner zu schonen aber auch die eigenen
zu schonen sie geht durch was
antisemitus Antisemitismus bedeutet
warum er in jeder Form zu verhindern ist
das ist keine impulshandlung gewesen das
ist eine klar geplante sehr lange
geplante Rede und übrigens auch im
ganzen Auftreten habck im schwarzen
Anzug mit schwarzer Krawatte eine Rede
die die Ernsthaftigkeit formuliert wenn
sie abgesprochen worden sein sollte mit
Olaf Scholz dann hat Scholz sich
vielleicht nicht bewusst welche Wucht
sie hat ich bezweifel das aber denn das
muss man ja auch sehen diese Koalition
das ist ja das Drama scheint gegenwärtig
eigentlich nichts mehr abzusprechen und
insofern glaube ich hat Robert Habeck
auch eines kenntlich machen wollen gegen
vor allem die ständigen Querschüsse
einer FDP die heute den kodeauschuss aus
Kompromiss wieder aufrollt die gestern
für die Abschaffung von Sozialleistung
für Flüchtlinge votiert die dann wieder
eine härtere
migrationsabschiebepolitik proferiert
alles klein klein gerichtet gegen die
Grünen zu allererst in permanenter
Selbstprofilierung gegen dieses klein
klein das auch nicht von einem kanstler
überwölbt wird der die richtlin der
Politik klar bestimmt setzt Robert
habbeck diese man muss es so sagen
staatsmännische Rede diese
Regierungserklärung und ich bezweifel
dass die mit Olaf Scholz abgesprochen
ist denn sie wirft natürlich sofort die
Frage auf warum hält der Kanzler nicht
eine solche Rede habg hat in dieser Rede
auch an Kritik nicht gespart z.B an den
Islamverbänden oder aber auch
an wen hat er noch benannt also die
Islamverbände zum einen die linke und
die Grünen genau die Linken Politiker
und Friedensaktivisten genau da hat er
auch Kritik an geäußert inwiefern hat
sie das überrascht welches Ziel hat er
damit auch gehabt nein es hat mich
überhaupt nicht überrascht weil habek ja
auch seine große Stärke dass er
analysieren kann er hat ja am Anfang
gesagt er will dieses Kneul entwirren er
will deutlich machen wer ist der ursach
wer wo ist die Ursache dieses
Antisemitismus wie versteckt sich
übrigens die Hamas permanent jetzt
gewissermaßen hinter den eigenen die sie
ja umbringt die sie zum Opfer bringt und
Israel wird für etwas verantwortlich
gemacht was den Ursprung im Terror der
Hamas hat und er macht eines und das
macht die Rede so stark er schützt auch
die eigene nicht er sagt deutlich dass
auch in der Umweltbewegung in Frid for
future wohlgemerkt frides for future
international dass dort eine absolute
verknappte Darstellung dieses Konflikts
steckt dass der Antikolonialismus die
Theorie des Antikolonialismus verkürzt
wenn sie Israel gewissermaßen zur
sperspitze des Kapitalismus eines
verbrecherischen Westen Westen
deklariert und damit unkennbar macht
dass der Ursprung im Terror der Hamas
liegt das macht er deutlich allerdings
schützt er auch freiders V future
Deutschland weil diese Sektion sich
explizit von der internationalen
Stoßrichtung distanziert hat also das
macht die Stärke aus eine analytisch
ganz klare Rede die auf eines verweist
das Grundübel eines Antisemitismus der
momentan in einer Dimension in
Deutschland wieder aufbricht wie wir es
uns über jahrelang nicht haben
vorstellen können Einschätzung zu einer
bemerk
Rede und zu einem bemerkenswerten Video
von Wirtschaftsminister Robert habbeck
vom Politikwissenschaftler und
Publizisten Albrecht von Lucke vielen
Dank dafür ich danke Ihnen